over the years you bazoft hasn't been
afraid to switch up the formula of its
uber popular action-adventure historical
park or further collecting franchise
assassin's creed there was the year they
dabbled some would say unsuccessfully
with tower defense that weird
hide-and-seek bit in assassin's creed 3
and of course who could forget newborn
simulator 2009 edition but now we're in
2014 an assassin's creed has made the
leap of faith to next generation
consoles with its latest edition unity
and with the jump comes a bunch of new
additions and changes to the norm so
here's 10 things to look out for on your
next outing in the Animus well let's
start with the most obvious addition
we've got a brand new assassin to take
for a tumble
Altea young Ezio slightly older Ezio old
Ezio Haytham Connor Aveline a Diwali and
Edward will miss you
young Connor will miss you most of all
but now it's Arno Dorian's time to shine
the French Austrian assassin comes
suited and booted with a gritty
backstory after his assassin father and
his Templar adopted father are murdered
with Arno framed for the latter crime he
embroiled himself in the French
Revolution to squeeze out or kill let's
just say kill the real troublemakers
he's brash charismatic and clearly has a
devastating case of the hansoms
which hasn't gone unnoticed he's having
an ill-fated love affair with his
adopted sister the Templar Elise de la
Sayer
every assassin comes with their own
unique addition to the regular Arsenal
our nose is the Phantom blade a wrists
bound mini crossbow that fires both
lethal and non-lethal projectiles but
can be used as a hidden blade in close
encounters so basically it's the Swiss
Army knife of wrist blades Abstergo are
dropping us off in Paris and it's
definitely worth taking the time to
admire the view rome wasn't built in a
day and neither was the French capital
UB spent 1287 days recreating the city
spending upwards of a year on the huge
landmark notre dam which was recreated
to an impressive one-to-one scale the
whole city is divided into distinct
districts each with their own aesthetic
and NPCs to boot in a Paris is roughly
to a one-to-one scale with the outer
limits of the city hitting around one to
six previous assassin games have been
very much outdoorsy affairs in ACU the
interiors of more than 25% of Paris's
buildings are explorable and you're able
to access them without hitting a single
load screen so if you add together the
map size plus the interiors and the
catacombs beneath the city you're
looking at a game that's three times
larger than Black Flag's landmass
hold down that right trigger because it
is freerunning time the new parkour up
and parkour down systems give you much
more control so you can pick the exact
path you want Arno to take along the
rooftops of Paris the new controlled
descent allows you to well control your
descent meaning you don't have to keep
an eye out for a haystack in order to
get back to street level as assassins
should neither be seen nor heard UB has
beefed up the usual stealth mechanics
for unity now at the touch of a button
Arno ducks into stealth mode where the
silent footballs make sneaking up on
enemies much easier not only that but
there's finally a decent cover system so
you can hug corners and duck behind
tables to your heart's content with a
splint to sell esque shadow of your last
known location left behind and if you
get busted the push to next-gen means
that the game can handle up to five
thousand NPCs on screen at one time so
mixing with a huge crowd to lose some
heat is a viable option
combats had a bit of a switch up most
notably kill streaks and counter kills
argon swordplay and ACU takes its
inspiration from fencing and is based
more on timing and flow you've still got
combat moves like the parry dodge tackle
and the returning heavy attack but you
need to keep your wits about you as the
AI has been beefed up too they can
overpower you quite quickly if you get
too cocky
and of course there's a ton of sidequest
content to fill your assassin boots with
Arno can solve various murders around
the city because apparently you get your
detectives license with your Brotherhood
induction pack there's collectibles
contracts to pick up life stories of
famous persons like Madame Tussauds to
uncover and Nostradamus quests the great
prophet lived in Paris for a time and an
ACU has left some clues around the city
to take any who follow them on a great
treasure hunt to find some sweet sweet
gubbins
we've played dress-up in Assassin's
before but the system goes much deeper
in unity mixing and matching our nose
gear can give great gameplay benefits
like increasing the time you can stay
hidden in a crowd or the strength of
your Eagle sense using XP gained by
completing missions you can specialize
in health ranged attacks stealth and
melee skills and gear you've equipped in
single player carry over into the story
based co-op missions so you're always
playing as your are no you can
specialize in one of four unique co-op
skills plan with your friends
accordingly and you become a formidable
team to get started just head to the
place where all the best laid plans are
formed the pub and if your friends ghost
is in there you can quickly join them to
either assassinate a foe or sabotage and
execution if your friends aren't online
you can be matched with strangers online
or have a crack at the mission yourself
Acey use mission structure is much more
fluid than previous installments there's
two main kinds the first of which the
adaptive mission mechanic or AMM adapts
to how you play so if you tale a guard
and get spotted the game automatically
switches from a tail mission into a
chase if you lose him it becomes a
locate mission which means there's no
more unfair D synchronizations the
second main mission type is the black
box a change to the regular
assassination the foe is plunked inside
a slice of the open world and then
you're let loose to create opportunities
and find your own path to the target the
mission doesn't end with a gurgling
speech in the killing blow you got
yourself in you have to be able to get
yourself out to
so there we have it 10 big new auditions
and switch ups to Assassin's Creed unity
which are you most excited about any big
changes you'd like to see where and when
would you like the series to go next let
me know in the comments for all the
latest historical assassinations make
sure you keep your eye on gamespot